I think government should do three
things because I would argue that we're
actually having a bit of a crisis right
now and I just got stuck in hideous
traffic coming across London.
You know,
London has an infrastructure problem but
the web has a much,
much bigger internet.
Sorry.
It has a much,
much bigger infrastructure problem if
you like and I think the government
should focus on three things.
Firstly,
we have got to improve the state of our
digital infrastructure urgently.
You know,
you don't have to be a rocket scientist
to see that South Korea knock it out of
the park all the time in terms of the
economy and productivity,
partly because they have that superfast
infrastructure.
That's one big piece of the puzzle and
somewhere that government can be more
aggressive.
Secondly,
we have an absolute crisis in gender on
the Internet.
Massive,
huge,
enormous.
The percentage of women in the tech and
creative industries.
I saw a report just this week have gone
down.
There are now nearly doubled the
percentage of women in parliament that
is probably marginally older than the
tech sector double.
It's a disaster.
It's a disaster because power,
money,
product design,
everything is worse and imbalanced and
asymmetrical.
So that's the second thing where I think
they should intervene.
And the third thing is that q and a
broad,
a broad,
broader skills crisis,
which I worked on for a while,
and now we still have massive issue with
the code and the jobs that we need to
fill and a massive issue in broader
digital skills,
let alone the skills of our
establishment and parliamentarians.
And they had three,
to me,
very tangible areas that government
could intervene.
They don't even have to touch a big tech
company to make a big shift in those
areas.